so funny people are like i love how
cody keeps talking about learning
spanish when he says the same [ __ ]
phrases it's the same two word phrases
i've ever had speaking of spanish and
bad [ __ ] subtitles i've been watching
the new season of narcos by the way very
funny yeah is it fire
it's good okay um
but i'm like
i'm dying laughing because some of those
captions are horrible it's so funny
really yeah
like some you know sometimes they'll say
something like with actual meaning like
you know uh i'm not sure you know like
like it'll be expressive or it'll it'll
be like
yeah i guess that sounds good and then
like the caption would be like all good
or that's too bad like that's not at all
what the [ __ ] that means are they like
automating these now or something i have
to dude dude i i was reading something
about netflix and how they're
so by far the leader globally in
streaming
because they're able to take these
properties and make them popular in like
across the world like squid games for
example yeah so they must be doing
something it has to be captions that's
somewhat automated it has to be because
um
i would have i would imagine like
whatever is doing that is written in a
way where it may pick up on the
expression but it's like
translate it to the like most
general statement so i bet you there's
like a default
like a script for all of it because then
it's probably very easy to translate
that sounds good or it's all good yeah
in 40 different languages i wasn't like
cool roll it out everywhere yeah it's so
interesting i think
like even content networks now other
ones like not the big streamers like hbo
probably those shows two are pretty big
globally but like all the other ones
they're making properties that are big
in the states and pretty much that's it
i think
and then if you go to netflix and you go
to use expressvpn or whatever you change
your location in every single country it
doesn't matter
squid games is number one that's nuts
that's crazy wow that's the power of
netflix yeah
damn yeah yeah they know what they're
doing yeah
weird that globally people would relate
to um drastic measures to get ahead in
life
[Laughter]
yeah it's crazy yeah
what
is that a political statement yeah i'm
just joking that like
everyone can relate to [ __ ] wanting
to kill someone for 100 million i agree
i do i do actually kind of
i kind of like the criticisms that
people are giving mr beast a little bit
oh uh what are they saying like it's
basically like how do you not see the
irony and recreating the squid games as
a rich influencer like yeah just
you know this whole thing is a
commentary
on how [ __ ] up the world is and
inequality and stuff but to a point that
you mr b's is like i have enough money
just to make that [ __ ] actually real
it's so funny i mean i know he's just
having fun and it's just like to him
it's just like entertainment which yeah
it is i think at the end of the day
but it's also kind of funny to
miss that how much better would you feel
if in the squid games actual show if
when the guy removed his mask it was mr
b so you'd be like oh well yeah it's
fine yeah yeah
he's a good guy
it's fine
you know he's doing for the ocean there
there is irony but
he it like you know his channel is one
big
non-profit organization it's very much
for profit but he also does donate a lot
well i think he's non-profit in the way
that he makes so much profit that he can
be non-profit
yeah that's the way it works yeah like
he can give away 40 cars yeah look at
this beast philanthropy he does it all
that's 6.3 million subs oh mr beast
reacts as a [ __ ] ton of stuff i mean he
does
everything and anything
huh only one a month
beast
it's kind of weird kind of weird
typically philanthropy
seems like a year-round thing
you know what's funny is that
his brand
his brand and you know the way he runs
his business
obviously everyone is under the
impression that he puts all the money
back into the videos and it
you know to
it seems like that's true yeah and
especially like with this team sees
thing it seems like that's real but one
day i want to just just to show up with
some crazy like bust down ap yeah and
not
not even refer to it shows up to youtube
like the youtube awards and a helicopter
yeah exactly yeah
yeah no i think yeah his i think his
his flex would be like on par with like
logan roy
you know yeah like backseat of a maybach
and then like the driver gets out of the
maybach and then stands by the car the
whole time yeah yeah then people come
out from the show and they're like wait
did that guys wait here the whole time
and then
mr b is like oh yeah he drives me
everywhere and then he leaves everyone's
like what do you mean hold on yeah
but i just meant like where you kind of
slowly start to see
the secret side of him oh okay that
really is kind of one of the
billionaires you know like he
comes to the red carpet at the shorty
awards or whatever and he's like thank
you guys so much thank you team seas if
you haven't heard about it beast
philanthropy please donate team seat yes
photographer like yeah yeah sleeve pops
down and there's like three rolexes yeah
yeah no a super like one of one ap yeah
yeah it has like mr beast in like vvs
diamonds underneath the face yeah
thank you guys so much team c's doc
everyone sees and then one of the
photographers like kind of reaches out
and touches him he's like oh
yeah ew
and his security runs up and
clotheslines them
[Laughter]
[ __ ] disgusting oh my god
[Laughter]
keep your grimy hands away from me
paparazzi [ __ ]
people were like oh my god god damn
yeah he snaps back into it anyways team
seas.org
that's picturing
or like what if it's more like petty
than that like
like like he has like the ap on his
wrist
he's like
i'm so excited we raised 10 million
dollars when he flips his hands around
to the camera it pulls his sleeve back
and it reveals the ap and then he puts
his hands back down but he makes a point
to turn to the camera to go ten million
dollars
oh like he does it on purpose yeah yeah
okay like he like keeps his arms short
so the sleeve rolls down like 10 million
dollars
or you know maybe uh
what's that [ __ ]
what's that strip club in miami 11 yeah
yeah
it's just one day they're just on their
instagram
mr beast in the house we're like what he
said [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
yeah just
getting just grinded
up on to
two women
biting his lips
[Music]
hundreds oh yeah
and they're just
oh no no no no no
you know what he does what
he [ __ ] he takes like a
he takes a [ __ ] red marker on some
white pants he draws a triangle
he's like everyone that can fit in this
triangle gets a hundred thousand dollars
that would be some squid games iron evil
let's go ladies
let's see what you got grind up on your
boy right now
[ __ ] hell dude that'd be so funny
he's just literally throwing
throwing like [ __ ] stacks of wands in
the air and just
drunk as [ __ ]
then he does a mr beast is in the house
then he does a co like a collab video
with mark rober mike rovers like i had
to design a device i could perfectly
spread ten thousand and ones in the club
for mr beast when he goes to eleven this
is how i did it now i'm not one to go to
the strip club but i did need to gather
some information so i tried a few out
and then it's mark rober in a small club
the chat's worth
getting grinded up on
he's got a st just got 101 just smash it
on her lower back
team skeet
[Laughter]
teamskeet.org